こんにちははじめ殺王です
皆さん
なんと
なーんとですね多分とタイトルにあると
思うんですけども調理器のコラボでござい
ますみなさん私肇社長がポケモンの中で誰
が一番好きなのかつご存知でしょうか
そうしぞう最強に汗という暴挙
ようやく
外れさぞとピッツっ頃
ん
いやは莫大スカをしのポケモンと安住さん
すぐコラボそんなを脱皮の買って居る子ら
のどれくらい前からだろう結構前から
ずっとこのプロジェクト進んでまして
ようやく今日みなさんにこのプロジェクト
の概要をお伝えすることが出来ますも超
big すぎて業やか言えることにすごい
なんか喜びというかやと言えたって感じに
なってますこのプロジェクトですねはず3
冊をかけるポケモンカードゲームかける
graniph 3つのコラボになって
おります凄いない薄々気付いてると思うん
ですけどもポケモンカードゲームもちろん
p 2種
カード化されますちょっと存知てると思う
んですけどこの後しますそして
graniph さんといえば結婚で交際
というか奇抜なイメージのあるプロされ
てるろ土産なんですけど戦2型もコラボし
て
中の可愛さを前面に押し出したスッといっ
たグッズもこの後紹介していきたいと
おもいますちなみにプロジェクトで
ピーラーモードへの前でやらせてもらって
ますっていうのはロゴプ座にありますどう
p なボード名前の由来なんですけども p
はピッ中そしてパニックの意味ですそして
だでは白ゆきているドクター弾みを
イメージした家実験室っていうね
laboratory ってゆーらぼん
エルド b が来ピョンってなっててそれ
がすごい市ミミっぽく見えたのでローグは
p 2の部にっぽくですしてもらいました
一応要素とはじめシャツおよそ詰め込んだ
プロジェクト女になっております
プロジェクト目ピラーもぜひ覚えて
くださいぜ早速
カード三井ましょうかいやもうね正直言っ
ていいですか
引くほど可愛いですよああああごめんなに
なってくれ入手方法とが普段とちょっと
説明するトレード実物見てくださいいき
ますよ
こちら
いやいや可愛いはいこちらが今回特別に
制作された p 2どポケモンカードです
もう名前出す日いたずら次の日中 hp
30可愛いねもうこれまでポケモンかあ
さんとめちゃくちゃの話し合ってこういう
女にしたいですとこういう表情がいいです
こういう感じがいいですとか色々もかなり
細部にこだわってていただきました
ブーブー分14秒214だあれの誕生日
でしょ
ブーブー言うことで暴れまわってもう en
フォルダー
誰のいいなんでしょうね後ろじゃあ女帝
細長いを投下しておりましたが誰なん
でしょうねすごく飯塚こんなんもう
また見ていきましょうかちょっと端
パーティー今より1回投げて表だったら
アイテム祇園前に中ダメージ裏なら自分の
ポケモン勢に中ためにつながった強くとも
ユーザ p っ結構なんかかわいい技に
しようと思ったんですけどなく7の
ポケモンの中開けそうだカミソリそうだ
こちらがいたそうだけれど今回の特別な
カードになっておりますそしてお待たせし
ましたモザイク外しますはいこちらがその
デザインを使って作られたグランディスた
んで販売される予定の t シャツです
いやーめっちゃかわいいでしょあの
やっぱり日本語のシャツより英語にした
ほうが僕かっこいいかなと思って色々これ
も graniph さんと相談しやって
おけがないラストとかも柄をおしゃれに t
シャツに落とし込んで作っていただいた
ティッシュになっております何でやろ本
入ってたりめちゃくちゃ気安く受けたの
イラストところが三養荘
戻し込めているのではないかなと思って
ますかわいいでしょこれだけじゃないです
よ結構グッズアイテム準備しております
障害してくださいはいでは早速相手も紹介
していきましょうこちらが t シャツ
いたずら好きのピチューホワイトと
ブラックで展開しておりますただ限定でで
特定の店舗にだけこちらのグリーンレッド
グレーもあります詳しくが概要欄からラン
ください
グーテを小さくてこちらです近くに変わる
と思うんですけどエネルギーなんですよ
ポケカのな大木さんされ気ないんですよ
うちの t シャツ家という間の剣闘士の
t シャツ服部ポケカという形そういう元
のオシャレな t シャツに見えますけど
ここにポケモンカードのロゴが入ってて
ポケットってただねこれもまた可愛いよ
可愛いよポケット付きあらかわいす物件
ダメ花の刺繍がしてるんですよめっちゃ
早くですかそのため何とかに出る事に顧客
のデッキが減る大きさで
のチラッと宇宙の実習されてますちょっと
遊び心いっぱいのすぐ可愛い t シャツ
なってるんですけどこちらもぜひチェック
してみてくださいまだいいんですよハイ2
ではこちらです
たようやく分かりますポケモンカードの柄
で z 煌所ぴ2-4ルート入っていると
いう感じで真ん中にはポケモンカードの
老後が入ってますかーゲートカード t
シャツってやっぱりちょっと子供っぽく
なっちゃうに水だったからそこは何度
ファッションにしたいという思いを込めて
さりげなさを極限まで求めたあえて言うだ
からわかる人敗れるとあああの人ポケモン
買う好きな花っていうのがこういう
ロボットか近くで見たかなどこでもさんっ
て言ってみてここにも十分ですねされてい
ますがいるこのてるのキッズサイズ
ばっちりありますと質疑こちら riri
付きのシャツ芸姿勢も軍人さんといえば
このシャツのイメージが俺結構あります道
これはパッティングポケモンカードって
感じしないんですよ
シンプルに多さになるんですけど近く見て
みると
ああもうかわいい
かわいい振り3でピッチングデザイン刺繍
されていますね可愛すぎだとやっぱ肇社長
ということで胸ポケットからスライムが
溢れてるよっていうスライムとピッチでも
肇社長のピチュー何よ周りの柄まで
ポケモンカードなぁのグラメンと
ピッチャーのシュレットは
[音楽]
ブーバー結構ありますまあこっち
ラティス a power いいポーン
備中がほっバーチャルのないんですよな母
絶対ピカチュウだっ今までカー自分
ピカチュウだっっ知らんけどそれでも
ピチューが一番かわいいなと思っている
からさ全力プレーを押し出していけないと
思ったわけよね可愛いすぎるやっていいか
着いおじさんとかのためようにしっかり
リバーシブルでこっちだとエネルギーの
ハットになってもいいいいねちょっと夏に
なってくるんでまたボスとがしっかり
かぶった方がいいんじゃないかな次は
こちらですこれはね俺でまず普通に使おう
と思ってるんですけどマグカップではい
はじめピッチが童顔と書かれているマグ
カップのグラッですねこっちは裏側はザメ
が書いてあって思って名は p 2で
ずっとが安定化ポイントバージョンもあり
ますのでおい白と黒両方ありますずん全員
さんイラストはめっちゃいいよカラフルの
部屋で遊び吊ら化するピッチャーがマジで
可愛くてこういうマグカップはねもうね
ほんとずつ
それではこちらトートバッグです
ペンション t 出すと同じデザインの
トートバッグですね結構大きいから
いろいろ入れられそうだサイズがになって
いる姉おおっにポケットが入ってるんです
お仕えしていいかなと思いますそして最後
はこちら
スニーカーです歳でデザインが違うんです
けどもこっちはポケモンカードゲームの
老後スライヴとエネルギーがデザインされ
て言って逆側にはですねピッチャーが
パーンと書いてありますちょっと入って
みる
運ちゃんいいところ下げいけないからさー
エネルギーのデザインとか先や先生の絶対
めっちゃかわいいですこのスニーカーの
普通のも販売されるので是非チェックして
下さい入ってな数のコラボグッズになって
おりますけどでしょ一
にこんなにフォーカスされた風呂敷今まで
ありました俺はもう受賞筆宣伝大使として
今回のこのプロジェクトでピッチの可愛さ
をように布教したいと思っておりますねお
待たせいたしました美人のカードの入場
方法なんですけれども配布場所がグラニフ
の国内店舗全93店舗ありますグレーの
店舗とグラフィックの公式のオンライン
ストアとポケモンセンターでも配布され
ますで配布条件なんですけどもビーラボの
アイテムを1点以上ご購入の方にせ先着で
プレゼントになりますちーシャツとか購入
するとついてくれてかつポケモンセンター
では期間中ポケモンセンターでの p ラボ
にかかわらずアイテムを購入された方に
先着でプレゼントになります公明したら
ついてくれたんだっけシンプルに入って
入りますえもー混ぜ一生の記念というか
もう俺が
か方だと思ってるから皆さんも手に入れて
くださいカバーするディスプレイフレーム
に入れさせてもらいましたとして限定の
ショッパーがあるんですよねサー可愛く
ないかフィジーのショッパーですダメ感
そして裏には
伊良部のロゴが書いてありますこの
ショッパーでグラに入る限定列に入ります
グラニフの国内店舗と braniff
残しオンラインストアで選ばれても一定
以上ご購入の方に先着でプレゼントになり
ますこれはかわいいのでぜひとも手に入れ
てくださいうわぁ
君が主役だよなんかこの猿使えそうな気が
してきたんだけど呼吸器官の前方ぜひ持っ
て使って言って作っております万寿台
かわいいで一番そしてあのこの勢いで言わ
せていただきます始め冊を主催ポケカの
大会開きます使いさんに土は6月の4日の
土曜日場所はイオンモール浜松市野
シーフォに行こうの静岡の浜松ですね
そちらで開催します詳しくはポケモン
カードゲーム公式サイトをご確認下さい
あの
俺ボケが強いんですこういう機会にぜひ皆
のポケモンカードを戦いたいなと思って
待遇を開かせていただきますはいという
わけでも本当吉酎が好きすぎてスピッツ
するともうね紅蓮どうもずっと集めまくっ
てましたもうこれ以上ないくらい幸せ
もしのポケモンとのこれほどお空でござい
ますねもう2度とない機会だと思うので
是非皆3 p 2のグッズそして東京
ガード手に入れてみてくださいじゃん
[音楽]
me